Bravo con about to be on the biggest
watch happens live ever how's the
experience so far
I'm always stoked about all of these
experiences and it feels so Bravo just
keeps outdoing itself so I'm at a 10
right now it's really it's really
amusing all right I know you guys
already shot the reunion what is going
to surprise us about that reunion okay
well a lot comes out I think not
surprising Vicki and Kelly go at it
again but actually I do you think that
the outcome of that I found to be I was
surprised by myself sitting there on the
couch it was very interesting to me what
happened I was not expecting at all I'm
excited for people to see because I
think it was very out of character for
the characters and I'm really interested
to see how everybody you know responds
to that and also I talked a lot about
some of the more recent things that
happened with Matt which you know
obviously is unfortunate and really
tough to talk about and I hadn't even
talked about some of this stuff even
with my therapist yet so you know I'll
just tell my letter that came out
so that's obviously gonna be interesting
to Google yeah and he said he was really
proud of how much you opened up on that
couch yeah I did you know decision I
think it takes me time with everything
because I'm not an oversharer and I do
too it I think was first has to be a
part of this they were like just be
yourself and part of myself is I I don't
share that stuff a lot and so it's a new
thing for me but what I found this year
was when you do share you actually do
feel a lot better and I do feel like you
keep these negative things and it's like
following up poison so I let it go this
year and I let that go at the Reunion
and it actually ultimately it makes me
feel feel good it's like I left it there
what is the update on you and Matt it's
been a real roller coaster where do
things stand today I would say it's
still a roller coaster but it's a
child-friendly roller coaster you know
it's not so gnarly anymore we could be
always Co apparently I'm proud of us you
know I really am and we do at the end of
the day it's like Matt and I have
problems with each other but we both of
us him - we always for the kids burps
which is really good we still
communicate we still exchange the
parents he mat actually sat down with my
new boyfriend I know that crazy and you
were expecting his reaction to you being
in a relationship - not because I mean
twisted it wasn't good it wasn't good at
first it was bad but then I think
ultimately this is what happens it's
like you want to get upset about things
you want to be angry about things but
then you look at your children and you
say you know what no I'm not gonna do
that and I'm so proud of him for doing
the right thing and as soon as he did he
sat down with Travis and they met he
text me right after like don't work you
know as I was like sitting there like oh
my god and he's like don't worry he's
like he's a really nice guy it's okay
and even then like I came here Travis
see if he's here but he stayed behind a
day he had my kiddos they did Zach and
off of the kids like Travis - Matt I'm
like this is bizarre your new normal but
it's mainly normal
and it feels really good to get to that
point how long and you and Travis been
together honestly it's been only a
minute but we fell really fast like I
think I knew that Travis was like it
because I don't fall fast and I really
don't like anyone so I knew that I liked
him before anything about him it was
just like we had this instant connection
it was really good we're like we've been
through a lot of the same things we have
the same point of view in a lot of like
just like life aspect and value system
and stuff like that and it just it
really works it's just a kind good man
do you want to get married again I'm not
opposed to it I think at first I was
like I don't need that I don't know
today was like try to like make a point
and then like you know take a stance and
then I'm like yeah I changed my mind but
like on ugg boots like at first I was
like oh they're ugly boots I've never
met and then I was like wearing odds all
the time you know so comfortable very
functional um but yeah so like with
Travis like he definitely opens my mind
to marriage but I don't need it you know
what I mean like I'm not ring Thursday I
feel so good with him and I feel like we
already have more of a commitment and I
ever had in my own marriage that I'm
good it feels really good did I perceive
a little shade there with ringing
thirsty one of your co-stars is
flattering shade although her ring could
provide adequate shade her all of her
cast members it's like a hat really it's
cute
I'm it's you know I'm really happy for
Kellie and you know what I think that is
important to her and I'm not I'm not
here to judge her say that's not
important it's just not my jam something
you know to wrap things up here and you
told me there's a blow-up to end all
blow ups at your guys's reunion did you
view it that way
Oh blow-up dolls Lola oh yeah well it
did it blew up and then it and then and
then and then it's interesting to see
how everything lands you know it's like
it's like if there's an explosion
there's shrapnel everywhere but it
settles you know and it's interesting to
see where everything settles sort of
back into place yeah we all walk in with
a limp but we made it out
[Music]